if you want to know how one location
from Stephen King's 1977 novel The
Shining made a little cameo in dr. sleep
they'll stick around at the end of this
video this video is brought to you by
privacy com privacy calm once you buy
things online using virtual cards
instead of real ones just like how Danny
and Abra fake their location from rose
and her gang in dr. sleep privacy has
rolled out a few new product options so
keep watching to learn more and is a
special treat for my things you missed
viewers you'll get five dollars to spend
on your first purchase that's free money
that you can use to purchase anything
online go to privacy calm / sees these
worlds to sign up now the shining is my
favorite movie of all time and it came
out 39 years ago in May of 1980 the
prologue of dr. sleep where rose and her
Colts eat the steam of the little girl
violets takes place in Florida in 1980
which is where Halloran was during the
Overlook Hotels offseason in The Shining
I'm not in I'm calling from Stapleton
Airport what the hell you doing down
there well I just got in from Miami and
I gotta get up to the Overlook today
Rose and her gang have the ability to
sense the biggest shiners in the country
and go after that is it possible that
they came to Florida to get Halloran
when they heard him trying to reach Dany
at the Overlook Hotel but missed him and
took violet as a consolation prize
another homage to the year 1980 is seen
during the exterior of a bruised house
the street number is 1980 dr. sleep
features a musical score that's very
similar to that of the shining where
director Stanley Kubrick used almost all
classical music from the eerie haunting
build of béla bartók's music for Strings
percussion and celesta use when Danny
and Jack have the one-on-one talk in the
hotel room being referenced in the music
that we hear early on in the trailer
community do the big pulsating tribal
drums that echoed through the massive
empty rooms of the overload following
Danny to Florida New Jersey to the
middle of nowhere and back to Colorado
but the shining also features a couple
of jazz pieces which can be heard when
the hotel is showing off events of days
past like Henry Hall's home which
celebrates Jack Torrance is homecoming
to the gold ballroom and Al boli and Ray
Nobles it's all forgotten now which
plays lager ad tries to get Jack to
remember
his role at the Overlook to correct his
family and protects the hotel but I
corrected them sir and when my wife
tried to prevent me from doing my duty
corrected these songs can be heard in
dr. sleep on the nomads radio while they
camp out and try to tune into the mind
of a shiner with a lot of steam for them
to capture next which reminded me of the
line from a bruises I know that head of
yours is like a radio so perhaps Rose
and her gang are also picking up on some
evil signals being broadcasted from the
Overlook it's during these dream hunting
sequences that dr. sleep also references
a concept seen elsewhere in the writings
of Stephen King Rose invades the mind of
a buret while she's asleep and sees a
wall covered with filing cabinets with
memories and important facts about her
life Kings 2001 novel dreamcatcher gives
us a look into the mind of the character
Jones who similarly files his memories
away to a warehouse resembling a
building in Derry called tracker brush
shipping but a bruise my and dr. sleep
is far more prepared to defend itself of
course most of the connections to King's
writing in this movie are gonna be
connections to the source material
dr. sleep and its prequel The Shining
for many movie fans when they think of
the most cursed room at the Overlook
they think of room 237
but the infamous room number was changed
from room to 1/7 in the novel this is
because of a request made by the hotel
where the exterior were filmed the
Timberline Lodge the hotel and perhaps
one of the worst marketing blunders of
all time feared that people would be too
scared to stay in room 2 1 7 dr. sleep
makes a little homage to the original
room number when Danny Torrance first
starts working at the hospice in New
Jersey he sees the cat as he wander into
the room of a dying patient the first
instance of him earning his nickname and
dr. sleep and the room number on the
door is 2 1 7 there's also the fact that
Danny like his father Jack before him
has become an alcoholic Jack's
alcoholism is present in Kubrick's
adaptation but is focused on much more
in a novel where Jack has a catchphrase
associated with his drunken beatings of
Danny come on and take your medicine
take it like a man now despite this line
never appearing in the 1980 film it does
make a comeback at the end of dr. sleep
where Danny comes face to face one more
time with his father at the bar in the
Gold Room
they do know that Jack Nicholson is
still alive right
he also pours a glass of Jack Daniels
which is symbolic of the fact that both
Jack and Dan resorted to alcoholism at
some points but the Overlook itself
would not be the only major connection
to Stanley Kubrick's psychological
horror masterpiece and when we return
I'll have even more hidden connections
featured in dr. sleep one scene I found
particularly interesting in dr. sleep
was right after Rose went into a bruised
mind and saw the inside of her room
abra decides to rearrange her furniture
and make it look like a different room
to protect her privacy and that got me
thinking
any time we buy things online were
opening up our windows for merchants and
their data partners to see our personal
information without our consent
that's where privacy calm can protect
you they make it super easy to protect
your financial life online by generating
a virtual card numbers that hide your
real bank information so you never have
to worry about strangers seeing the info
attached to your accounts they also let
you set limits on each virtual card to
protect you from unwanted charges going
through privacy calm as always is
totally free to use you can create up to
12 virtual cards per month and they've
also introduced two new plans Pro is $10
per month gives you everything from the
free plan plus 1% cash back on all
purchases 36 cards per month and even
more privacy and security features if
you're using privacy calm for a team or
small business you'll want the team plan
it's $25 per month and gives you access
to everything from the pro version plus
dedicated account management 60 cards
per month and transaction limits
tailored to your business needs if you
go to my link privacy calm / Suzy's
world you'll get $5 for free to spend on
literally whatever you want so there's
no reason not to do it just look for the
link in the description privacy calm /
Suzy's world The Shining is well known
and not only for its genius director but
also its unbelievable performances from
Jack Nicholson Shelley Duvall Danny
Lloyd and Scatman Crothers dr. sleep
chose to recast these characters even
though realistic visual effects now
exist so the characters had to recreate
the performances of the actors in the
shining in the prologue when Danny's
talking to dick hallorann in the bench
Wendy comes up screaming down his name
crying as if she'd been looking for him
in a panic which is a mimic of the
penultimate scene of The Shining
[Music]
there's also a facial expression that
fans have dubbed the Kubrick stare in
which a character tilts their chin down
while looking up to make them look at
deviously sinister on camera during the
ambush scene where Danny and Billy hide
out in the woods with rifles to take
down the nomads who are coming for a
bruh the last one standing is snakebite
Andy who emerges from the trailer
donning the signature Kubrick Ian look
one of the scenes where Jack can be seen
with a creepy expression in the shining
is while he's staring at Wendy and Danny
in the miniature hedge maze so I took it
as no coincidence that the town that
adults Danny ends up in also has a
miniature model version that Danny spent
some time helping to build it is here
where he meets Billy who introduces him
to the man that he would interview with
for the job at the hospice and that
interview takes place in a room that's
identical to the room that Jack
interviewed in for the caretaker job at
the Overlook the wall color layout
window placement is flag that pen the
cup the artwork and even some of the
camera angles used to shoot it or a
directory creation of Jack's interview
for both characters it represents a
point of no return in the story other
parallels between Jack and Danny exists
up and down the plots I mentioned the
fact that they're both alcoholics and
Danny brings this up during one of the
AAA meetings saying that he's standing
where his father once stood and that
idea comes back when he and Rose face
off in the overlooks Colorado lounge and
he asked her if she knows where she's
standing the ax fight between Danny and
Rose also goes up and down those stairs
being blocked out exactly how the fight
between Jack and Wendy went down in
nearly 40 years prior but the
connections of the shining do not end
there during the flashback Wendy and
Danny can be seen watching a Bugs Bunny
cartoon that illustrates the current
state of affairs and connects to the
shirt that Danny wore in his first scene
in The Shining Bugs Bunny is chosen
because bugs catchphrase is and Danny's
nickname in the shining is doc which
carries over to current times where
Danny becomes known at the hospice as
dr. sleeve before we move on from Danny
one other thing I noticed was during the
end credits
Danny Lloyd the actor who played Danny
Torrance in The Shining was listed as
spectator I'm guessing he may have made
his cameo at the movie theater or the
Little League game before dr. sleep he
hadn't acted since 1982
but the spooky part is that after he
decided to quit acting he grew up and
became a teacher just as Jack Torrance
was in The Shining
unfortunately one actor who could not
have come back to reprise his role with
Scatman Crothers who passed away in 1986
his character dick hallorann has a final
conversation with Danny and dr. sleep
where Danny describes each of the ghosts
of the over looks past that he locked
away in Halloran's box the last of which
was horse Derwent we spat out his
signature phrase rates party isn't it
as the box locked him away there are two
things you might have missed here the
guy he's referring to seems to be this
guy from The Shining who's credited as
injured guest and who I dressed up as
for Halloween in 2012 the bald cap
didn't really work out so I ended up
just being a younger version of injured
guest dr. sleep makes the suggestion
that injured guest is actually [ __ ] at
door wind a character from the history
of the Overlook Hotel in the novel Horus
was a millionaire inventor pilot film
producer and entrepreneur who bought and
renovated the hotel in 1945 and turned
the place into an entertainment
destination as well as adding a rock
court in the lawn the Overlook was
perhaps his one unsuccessful business
venture though and he sold the property
after losing three million dollars on it
I guess that the party wasn't so great
after all if you have any other things
you noticed in dr. sleep leave them in
the comments I would love to hear what
you all picked up on and don't forget to
go to privacy comm slash Easy's world
and get your free $5 the link will be in
the description and if you love horror
make sure you subscribe to seize these
worlds for new Horrors every week bring
that DEATH BATTLE for notifications and
I'll see you in the next one assuming we
both survive